what makes a woman wifey material
it's definitely silent in here
all right what makes a woman wifey
material in your opinion
it doesn't matter I was gonna get you no
matter where you sit it's okay I'm
really not like we're we can yeah we can
talk about it together
um
oh can you come back to me let me let me
think is it a hard question
it's the way I would have to word it I
want to think about it properly like I
don't want to just it's a hard question
yeah
cool what do you think well if material
needs to be someone is going to be good
take care of yourself of herself and the
house
someone's gonna be in charge and of
everything and be happy with that's a
wife material for sure to take care of
the house and and what was it everything
everything that about the relationship
organizing the holidays being that
person organizing the holidays yeah yeah
like Manchester like exactly that's life
material
organizing holidays
no I want to answer I think of my mom oh
all right you can go first okay
you want me to go first or you want to
go first oh you can go first you sure
you sure no hold up hold up hold up hold
on have you thought of anything yet
because she's gonna go off what you not
say well have you thought of anything
yet
um yeah like okay cool let me say it
I feel like life material is like
someone that's like your piece someone
that you can go to like that's always
got your back that will help you through
stuff that will you can actually be your
true self with someone as a
granddaughter that you know wants to be
able to hustle with you you know I mean
sees your vision and goes with it as
well like I said as I said before I'm
quite a traditional girl like I want my
man to call you yeah you know and I
follow you know I'll do my own thing I
have my own thing but I'm helping him be
his best him because when he's his best
I'm even better personally I know that
sounds mad but if his money is up and
I've helped him get there he's gonna
treat me because I helped him get there
okay cool if you could just list it
because like list it in bullet points
where you think wifey material looks
like just bullet points of what you said
um
they're peace
someone that cooks cleans
e you know
I know it sounds bad no I don't it don't
sound much just like see what you're
thinking it yeah and makes them happy
obviously
good at communicating
just the simple stuff I feel like it's
simple yeah and then I mean some guys
feel like the girls that don't go out
and party all the time
and dress appropriately
you know those are the minor ones okay
over to you guys can I go first mom go
ahead thank you okay so first off I
think of some things my mother taught me
all right so shout out Jen sorry Mom
sorry sorry I know you hate it when I do
that
okay so first of all I feel like a wife
material is someone that values family
the family has to come before her so a
lot of times like women are like oh I
need to leave to be happy I need to do
no no no the family comes before you
okay that's number one two you can't be
sleeping around the whole town I'm sorry
you know if you slept with the whole
football team you're probably not wife
material all right all right three young
you can't be too old all right we're not
trying to have yet
70 like if you're 60 you're looking for
a husband 40 looking for a husband where
have you been the last 20 years probably
with the football team you know what I
mean
also okay so when I think of skills I
think the ideal wife would be very clean
right picks up after her self picks up
after the kids can make sure the home is
clean on top of that I think cooking
from scratch this is what I'm trying to
learn my mom's trying to teach me this
soon so I can be more wifey you know
what I mean
and cooking from scratch I think would
be great because a lot of times girls
are like I cook I cook well how many
meals have you cooked from scratch this
week this week right you know
can you bake a cake from scratch can you
bake a pie from scratch because y'all
don't have Thanksgiving here but we have
Thanksgiving are you coming to
Thanksgiving with the pie that you
bought from Tesco are you coming to
Thanksgiving with the pie you baked
yourself all right just describe an
American Mom I don't think European
women get in this book you guys you guys
have different holidays here but it's
the same thing what are the kids gonna
eat the kids have to eat something are
you feeding them good food are you
feeding them food well I wonder sorry
but when you said wifey I didn't know
there was like kids involved no but I do
it qualities
if I'm a man if I'm a man and I see you
I can just take you and so this is what
I would like think would be ideal so a
girl that works with kids all the time
so she already knows how to deal with
kids work with kids girl that cooks all
the time a guy can just say oh perfect
you already know how to do what I need
you to do right
um I also think a girl that really
supports her man and
you know wants the best for him
nurturing loyal loyalty is really
important yeah those are just Mom what
did I miss go off mom
I think a wife material is somebody
who's a nest Builder so a nest Builder
like you know I can I know how to cook I
know how to clean I know how to take
care of kids I'm going to defend my Nest
I'm going to protect my Nest I'm going
to build my Nest I'm going to create
family I mean in my in our family if uh
anybody wants to like mess with any of
the Traditions like it's gonna hit the
fan yeah it isn't pretty so I think but
that's my role and so when I look at
wife material I that's that's what I
think uh makes that be true and how and
our house we have
bones everyone takes pictures with Santa
every year no matter how old you are
yeah I make my kids go to the mall and
get pictures of Santa Christmas like
like all of them
her family's more
leaves more her so if she has to go out
on a Saturday night or spend time with
her family she's gonna pick her family
every time but a lot of times women just
live their lives for themselves
don't care about their family haven't
even seen their family in three years
and then say I'm wife material well you
don't have any you don't even spend time
with the family you got
cool all right let me say from a guy's
perspective of like wifey material yeah
uh first things first yeah very family
orientated yeah that's absolutely 100
yeah another thing is the way you carry
yourself like a lot of girls out there
are just constantly advertising
themselves with the way they carry
themselves the way they dress the way
they portray themselves on social media
etc etc like if you want to look like a
lady of the night then obviously guys
are not gonna perceive you as wifey
material I'm sorry that's just the way
it is like a lot of modern women try to
fight that oh I should be allowed to
wear what I want yeah wear what you want
and be single buff that's it or be for
recreational use it's up to you
whichever one you want you get what I'm
saying but um yeah the way you carry
yourself the way you um dress like are
you a party girl are you the type that
you you want to be the life and soul the
party you want to be at every event I'm
sorry that's not wifey material you're
for everybody you get what I'm saying
and that's it you know what I'm saying
also you know like you said being a
man's piece like a lot of times that
like a buzzword these days a lot of
girls are saying that they don't even
know what that really means you get what
I'm saying like uh in my opinion a girl
that just tries her best not to bring
you any unnecessary headache
a lot of girls find that very very
difficult press one in the chat if you
if you agree or hit the super chat if
you agree because I know a lot of you
guys are going through that some of you
guys never had a girlfriend so you don't
know what I'm talking about but you will
one day
you will one day Ralph yeah and you know
just don't be annoying
um support what he's doing actually care
about him
saying like again more than women these
days it's all about you it's all about
your long laundry list of the things
that you want I want I gotta make six
figures so I want a guy that's six foot
I want a guy with six inches in the
pants or better I want a guy that is
emotionally available and emotional
intelligence and he's smart but he's got
a little bit of hood to him bro like
you're you're looking for a unicorn that
don't exist number one and a lot of
times you don't think about what you
actually bring to the guy's life because
look you don't care
you know wifey material broth and that's
it
yeah then although a lot of a lot of
chicks these days are hyper
materialistic money money money money
money listen as a guy I understand that
a woman will want a guy that can protect
and provide for her financially
physically etc etc yeah but if you are
hyper materialistic and you are consumed
with consumption you're not wifey
material not in my opinion and most guys
who do have money and I know guys that
are actually doing well they can spot
these kind of women very very easily you
know what I'm saying again recreational
use those are the type of girls that you
see in the music videos or whatever oh I
was dating this rapper I was dating this
athlete blah blah blah blah blah you
didn't get the ring you didn't win
anything he was just he was just box use
this extra box that's it and wife
material I would think wants to save the
family money too because again like wife
material thinks about the family before
her so she's not thinking about what
money he could spend on her she's
thinking about what money can I save for
the family yeah what was he gonna say
Glenn
I see I see you you little you wanted to
say something
I'm personally not like a materialistic
person like that but as I said me I
think when I was thinking I wasn't
figuring I wasn't talking about you no
no no no no no no no okay I mean like
when I was saying it I wasn't talking in
terms of a family I think I was talking
more in terms of just me and him like I
wasn't thinking about
um
the extension because once you have a
family that's a whole novel Dynamic but
you don't think when you're like seeing
a guy you're not thinking of like
potentially what the family would look
like how that would work
it just depends if you want to have
children but I think that's that's the
biggest factor and that's what you need
to ask when you're trying to take
someone seriously whether they want kids
or not because but I think that time
like it's an interview process like
dating what's the purpose if yeah you're
not interviewing and so to me you know
you should be looking at him for is he
going to be the type of Provider to
protect and provide for your family and
for you is it you know are you ready to
fulfill the role of being the nest
Builder yeah me I'm not even thinking
like that I'm young
when you said about the girls the way
the way they want to dress they can die
alone
in our generation no you said like uh
the guys would say but I would say no
wifey material in there for everybody
hold on hold on hold on I said they're
not wifey material they're for everybody
and recreational use you gotta be
careful because like with me um if you
say I said something I didn't say I'm
gonna pull you up like you're gonna say
well
material like the kind of girl the way
she dressed the way she showed herself
on Instagram whatever but I also think
our generation is not our dream to be
married with children that is the old
generation dreams the things are
changing quickly especially if you talk
about monogamy those days is something
that's not being easy without a divorce
especially in America you can tell about
the numbers in the UK or in Brazil so I
would say it's changing a lot the
conception of traditional family we had
in the past the things are changing a
lot the people are changing so the women
a lot of women doesn't want to get
married or have children oh that gone
gone do you think it's changing for good
or For Better or For Worse it depends it
depends on your point of view of course
it has to be worse it has to be worse
like I look at right now my mom is
terminally ill and so she had nine
children and her kids are taking care of
her it is a terrifying world to think
about all these single childless women
who are going to be warehoused and you
know by the system no one take care of
their grandparents the care system are
the one taking care of everyone and the
America is the same in Brazil we step in
to take care of the family but not in
this country correct me if I'm wrong
because then if you change the law if
you're living with your grandparents you
can Heritage the house but once you're
not there the government can take over
they had to change the law because there
is no much children looking after their
parents in this country but in America
is different because they don't they
don't have a life I don't know
cosign that at all because in my
community people look after their Elders
yes they do I don't think it's uh I
don't think it's
um country by country I think it's
family by family my mom had nine
children not all of them would take care
of her they just changed you know you
have a bunch of kids because you have a
bunch of kids somebody's
so these guys are just my insurance
policies as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible